today on the matt while show online
application forms now provide dozens of
gender options and sometimes man or
woman doesn't even make the list and
speaking of made-up terms a new poll
shows that almost no hispanic people use
the term la tinx and yet the left
continues to push it we'll talk about
all that today plus bill de blasio bans
young children from public
accommodations if they don't show their
vaccine papers the evil is so absurd and
over the top at this point as to almost
be cartoonish and salacious new details
emerge in the jesse smilet trial also a
company produces a suicide pod to help
people kill themselves and in our daily
cancellation we'll ask the question
why is everyone so ugly these days all
of that and more today on the matt walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
here's a gift you can give yourself for
christmas how about
aligning yourself with a company
supporting a company that supports you
rather than as we all do unfortunately
just in the fact that we uh we live in
this culture inevitably you're going to
be supporting a lot of companies giving
your money to a lot of companies that
hate you well when you get a chance to
support a company like charity mobile
you ought to do it charity mobile is the
pro-life phone company they partner with
you to automatically support the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and they've sent millions of
dollars to charities so far new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh
plus speaking of christmas you get a
christmas gift with every phone with
charity mobile while supplies last
charity mobile they make it easy to
switch if you're worried about the
convenience of it you can keep your
existing phone number and you may even
be able to keep your existing phone but
if you want a new phone they've got a
variety of options
from everything from from the basic flip
phones all the way up to the smartphones
and the latest 5g phones they've got all
that no contracts no termination fees no
risk with a 30 day guarantee so switch
to charity mobile and support the causes
you care about call them at
and mention 1-877-474-3662 code walsh so
a woman named sasha was filling out some
kind of online application form recently
and shared one part of that experience
on twitter at the section where it asks
for your gender a drop down menu appears
which you can see with 19 options
notice the order of their appearance
agender androgenin bigender demigender
gender fluid genderqueer pangender trans
man trans woman two-spirit gender not
listed declined to answer non-binary and
then cis male and cis female
now if you're wondering for some reason
demigender means somebody who is one
gender but not fully that gender so
perhaps a demigender is 82 man and the
other 18 is comprised of uh you know
other ingredients
human beings now like talk about
themselves like whiskey connoisseurs
might talk about the mash bill in a nice
bottle of bourbon yeah i'm 50 male 20
female uh 20 unicorn and 10 rye
pan gender by the way is someone who
doesn't connect with any particular
gender
uh but isn't that the same as demigender
and genderqueer and non-binary and
genderfluid and agender are these all
labels for the exact same thing which at
bottom is nonsensical in itself
yes of course but in a culture where
labels now take the place of personality
a person wants to accrue all of the
labels they can it's like the kind of
stat padding that a football team might
do in the fourth quarter when they keep
throwing passes even though they're up
by 25 with two minutes left they you
know they want to collect the stats for
their own sake just as the person in the
leftist lgbt cult collects labels for
their own sake
but the striking thing about this array
of options
is not what makes the list
but what doesn't
notice what's missing
the options for man and woman not there
these categories have been erased
instead sasha is a biological female who
knows that she is a female and
identifies as what she is has to settle
with the term cis female
but cis is an invented term made up by
the lgbt left with the express purpose
of making normal men and women seem like
one mere variation among an infinite
array of equal if not superior options
by calling normal women cis
you're placing them within the lgbt
framework
you cannot say the word cis male or cis
female in a non-critical way without
affirming every other gender identity
because cis exists in a universe
alongside those others
cis is meant to validate the other
choices while marginalizing itself
the last point is is made the
marginalization point is made in a not
so subtle way by by listing the cis
options last even though the list is
alphabetical otherwise
so they went outside of the alpha
alphabet alphabet's
alphabetization system there we go in
order to put cis at the bottom because
every other every other term there it's
all it's all alphabetical
and then but we're going to put cis at
the bottom even though it starts with c
kind of a visual representation of the
lgbt identity hierarchy marginalize
normalcy
make normal make normal seem abnormal
that's the goal here
it's a goal that has already been
accomplished largely through the
manipulation of language as always the
manipulation is top down elites come up
with it you know with these terms they
kind of workshop it and then they send
it out into the community demanding that
the plebes adopt it
perfect example of this is the term
latinx
which i guess they want us to pronounce
as latin x
but
both no matter how you pronounce it it
makes no sense
but really l-a-t-i-n-x would be la tinx
since that's what i'm calling it
it's the totally incoherent
gender-neutral term for latino that the
lgbt left concocted a few years ago the
daily wire has a report on how well it's
been received in the hispanic community
and
spoiler alert it has not been received
very well
they report on monday morning political
reported that a new poll indicated that
many hispanic american voters are
bothered by the term latinx possibly
contributing to the exodus of hispanic
voters from the democratic party
lettings has been introduced in recent
years by academics as a way to describe
hispanic voters without using the
feminine latina or the masculine latino
the national poll was taken between
november 17th and november 21st and
found that the effort to implement
latinx is turning off hispanics
according to politico only two percent
of those polled referred to themselves
as latinx while 68 called themselves
hispanic and 21 percent favored latino
or latina to describe their ethnic
background according to the survey from
bendixon and amandian international a
top democratic firm specializing in
latino outreach
more problematic for democrats 40
percent said letince bothers or offends
them to some degree and 30 said they'd
be less likely to support a politician
who or organization that uses the term
this latest poll is nearly identical to
a 2019 survey that found 98 percent of
hispanics preferred a term other than
latinx to describe their heritage at the
time the progressive founder of think
now mario karosako uh said that uh based
on the results he would advise my
colleagues across the various marketing
human resources journalism and
communication disciplines to avoid using
latinx as a descriptor for all latinos
well of course normal hispanic people
don't use the term or like it
if spanish is their primary or only
language
then they really can't use the term as
it's as it is unpronounceable in spanish
that's one of the many problems with it
spanish is a gendered language
every noun has a gender
so the word chair in spanish sia is
feminine the word for bench is masculine
el banco
and that's about the extent of the
spanish that i know three years of high
school spanish well spent in any case
the point is that you cannot impose
gender neutrality onto a fundamentally
gendered language without destroying the
language
the left to borrow their phrase is
colonizing the spanish language and
turning it into something else entirely
so this goes beyond trying to bully
spanish-speaking people into using a new
word they're trying to bully them into a
new language
the irony here is that if for whatever
reason the gendered nature of the word
latino or latina offends you there's
already another gender inclusive and
coherent and popular term that the
people in this community use almost 70
of them prefer it that is hispanic
so if you want a gender-neutral term for
latino people
why not just call them hispanic
well the answer is that hispanic already
exists
that's the problem and it's existed for
a long time
so when you say the word hispanic you
bring to mind people who live south of
our border
but the lgbt left doesn't want you to
think first of hispanic people when you
talk about hispanic people they want you
to think of themselves
everything and everyone must be defined
by reference to themselves and their
ideology
through le tinx they have essentially
inducted the entire
population of central and south america
all 600 million of them or so into the
lgbt leftist camp
normalcy is pushed further to the
fringes
now the good news at least is that
normal people reject this gibberish
the bad news is that even though nobody
likes it or wants it
still the term exists
and is pushed
and appears in official government
documents
and is used by major corporations
that shows the power of the leftist
elites to obtrude these changes into a
society onto a society against its will
now a few years from now after they have
hectored and threatened and cajoled and
manipulated at least a sizable minority
into using the term
a new political poll will be conducted
showing that hey now would you look at
that 35 percent of hispanics told a
pollster that they prefer the term
li-tinx
and when that happens the left will
celebrate the news and they'll call it
progress and evolution they'll say yeah
you look at that language changes on its
own
but it will be neither progress nor
evolution
not a natural evolution anyway
it will be rather the result of a
sustained psychological and social
campaign to change the way people speak
about themselves
and thus the way they see themselves
that as always is the ultimate goal
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
this holiday season how about a gift
that keeps on giving you joy and comfort
every day all year long a gift that
looks as good as it feels and a gift
that will actually pay for itself in
terms of how much more productive you'll
be at work i'm talking about giving
yourself the gift of the next chair this
is for yourself don't get anyone else
the next chair and because you know you
get this is this is for you you deserve
it um and i absolutely love mine i can
tell you it's by far the most
comfortable and ergonomic chair i've
ever used and honestly it's also
probably the coolest looking piece of
furniture i own not only is x chair the
world's greatest office chair but with
its patented lmx technology it doubles
as a massage chair and it can cool or
warm your back as well can your office
chair do that probably not so now is the
perfect time to purchase an x chair you
can buy early and buy now and here's
extra x chairs holiday gift to you save
a hundred dollars off your ex chair just
by purchasing
xchairwalsh.com now that's
extrawalsh.com
uh the letter x chair
walsh.com xjr is a 30-day guarantee of
complete comfort and you can finance
your purchase for as little as 30 a
month go to exchairwalsh.com and save
xchairwalsh.com all right
so by the way there there were some
people uh complaining in the comment
section you can see that we're all
decorated for christmas here as we
mentioned yesterday very very festive um
i had
uh
mentioned on the show that i wanted a i
wanted a six foot mechanical santa
behind me on the show waving that was
one of the things that i that i
requested
and i just talked to our producer
mckenna about it she said that um we
couldn't get approved to be about 700
for a mechanical santa
and that waves and somehow that that
budget was not approved so i'll have to
go talk to the higher-ups about that one
but we'll see what else we can do um
the biggest news that we have to really
start with aside from the decorations in
my studio i think the biggest news is
this
okay and i and i promise you i'm not
making this up
it is
walrus awareness week
okay it's on the calendar
it's real
this is the week to raise awareness
about walruses and about books
especially children's books that are
walrus-themed okay
like say my children's book johnny the
walrus
um
we didn't plan to coincide the launch of
johnny the walrus with walrus awareness
week but but it happened you know it was
faded to happen it's like written in the
stars
the the walrus uh constellation which
might exist aligned and and here we are
it's it's pretty amazing how how
perfectly this has all worked i'm a top
lgbt author it's walrus awareness week
why do we need walrus awareness i mean
who isn't aware of walruses already
and what if you're not aware why do you
need to be aware of them
what are we supposed to do with that
awareness besides buy my book
i don't know i can't answer that
this is just a week for people to go uh
you know for someone to say to you hey
hey did you know walruses exist
and the other person says yeah i did
know but thanks for reminding me and so
it's great that's what it's all about in
fact here's a we're going to play this
for some reason um
here's a i was i was looking up reports
on wallburst awareness week and there
are a lot of local news channels have
been have been talking about this
i'm a little bit offended that i i
watched about five different reports on
wallburst awareness week not one of them
mentioned my book johnny the walrus
which is available at johnnywalrus.com
but uh we'll watch this is a this is a
cbs affiliate um talking a little bit
about walruses and i figured let's just
let's watch this it is walrus awareness
week and what better time to talk with
our friends from seaworld about their
involvement they really are involved in
a lot of efforts but wallace
conservation consortium is one big one
this is pretty neat joining us at their
walrus exhibit is mitzi sinnott senior
animal care special mitzi thanks so much
for being here and who do you got there
this handsome boy is dozer
our 28 year old male and you guys he's
almost 4 000 pounds oh
man
they like to eat so so how much do they
eat in the day and what do they usually
like to consume
so right now he's eating 125 pounds of
fish a day so he gets herring he gets
clams sardines twin all kinds of stuff
so in the wild he would actually be able
to go find 125 pounds of food a day wow
pure body shaming
body shaming the walrus oh do they
really eat that much yes gary they eat
that much
he's 4 000 pounds made of pure lard
he lives in the damned arctic
what do you want him to do
want to make himself a like a nice greek
salad what do you want
outrageous um
but i guess this is why we need greater
walrus awareness and acceptance in
society so we don't have this kind of
body shaming
and also that you know to buy my book
johnnywalrus.com okay um
we'll move on
the uh okay we'll start here
from um from you know walruses which are
kind of weird looking we'll go from
there to new york where the mutant gumby
bill de blasio has announced new covent
measures going further
than anyone else has gone
so you know you notice the trend here as
as this as this wears on and wears on
um
people like bill de blasio
they're they're putting cover measures
in place that are stricter and stricter
okay so this is not getting more relaxed
and here's the latest from de blasio
we've got omicron as a new factor we've
got the colder weather which is going to
really create additional challenges with
the delta variant we've got holiday
gatherings we in new york city have
decided to
use a pre-emptive strike to really do
something bold to stop the further
growth of covet and the dangers it's
causing to all of us so
as of today we're going to announce a
first in the nation measure our health
commissioner will announce a vaccine
mandate for private sector employers
across the board
all private sector employers in new york
city will be covered by this vaccine
mandate as of december 27th we're going
to have some other measures as well to
really focus on maximizing vaccination
quickly so we can get ahead of omicron
and all the other challenges we're
facing right now with covet
okay so you see it puts up on the screen
there on the on the graphic
vaccine proof for indoor dining fitness
and entertainment required for children
ages 5 to 11.
the new york post has more info on that
part of it children's ages 5 to 11
reports must show proof of one
vaccination dose to eat out
see a show go to a movie theater visit a
fitness facility or attend indoor
entertainment venues by december 14th
kids over age 12 must have two doses by
december 27th unless they receive the
one shot johnson johnson vaccine
to bill de blasio first first launch the
key to nyc vaccine mandate for adults at
all public indoor venues in august but
now the new mandate also applies to many
school activities kids over five must
now be vaccinated to attend high risk
extracurricular activities like band
sports orchestra and dance in schools
so pull them out of school pull them out
of sports pull them out of all those
activities
tell them they can't they can't sit down
at a restaurant
they can't go watch a movie
children in many of these places
especially places like new york
were isolated for over a year
attending school through zoom meetings
and um and now you're going to isolate
them once again
we know that the suicide rate among kids
among adolescents especially
attempted suicides all of that
skyrocketed over the last year or two
um
and this is what this is what they're
doing in new york i mean this is pure
unadulterated evil
from bill de blasio
it's it's
i mean it's unthinkable but we have to
think about it because it's actually
happening
but it's unthinkable that you would you
would say to a five-year-old
show me your papers or you're not
allowed in this restaurant
all for a virus that poses almost no
serious threat to kids at all
and that's why many parents are hesitant
about getting the vaccine for their kids
you know why because because we have two
years of kovid
under our belts and there's a lot of
data
and we can make an informed data-driven
decision
and say you know what
if my kids get covered it's it's very
very very very very unlikely that
they'll get seriously ill from it
and even less likely that they'll die
from it
but then you look over at the vaccine
and you say uh you know what
we just started giving this this vaccine
to kids
i we don't know that we don't know much
about it
okay so this is a this is a in many ways
because it's new
it is therefore by definition an unknown
entity
for kids that
that's uh that young
it's a devil you know versus devil you
don't kind of thing
it's a very reasonable calculation that
parents make
and because many parents have made that
reasonable calculation
uh you're gonna punish the children
this man is uh did i mention that he's
evil
i mean sometimes
that that aspect can i you know can can
sometimes get lost in the fact that he's
such a goofy ridiculous stupid person
that doesn't make this any less evil
i mean what we're doing to kids how
we're treating them in this in this
society
is unconscionable
and i have to have to remind you again
that the reason that we're doing this
you know i'm sort of wasting my breath
here talking about well covet is not a
serious threat the children according to
the data it's not about the kids that's
not what it's about
this is all about the adults it's to
make the adults feel comfortable
well it's two things it's power
for the people in charge
so this is a power trip this is a power
move
um
and it's also to make adults feel
comfortable
now
he mentioned the omicron as uh
as one of the the reasons why they have
to put all these measures in place
because this omnicorn variant's out
there and uh it's really terrible and
then so we got to put all this stuff in
place because of the omnicorn well let's
go to the guardian
and uh re they've got a report here's
what they say about omnicorn the
omnicorn variant has been detected in at
least 38 countries but
no deaths have yet been reported
according to the world health
organization i mean warnings that it
could damage the global economic
recovery the u.s and australia became
the latest countries to confirm locally
transmitted cases of the variant as
omnicorn infections push south africa's
total cases past 3 million
the who has warned it could take weeks
to determine how infectious the variant
is whether it causes more severe illness
and how effective treatments and
vaccines are against it the who
emergency director michael ryan said
we're going to get the answers that
everybody out there needs but according
to the data we have right now it is um
it is
not at all lethal according to the data
now there's a doctor on twitter um
dr abby daskaloo and uh he's got some a
chart here that he put up
and he tweeted out uh omnicorn and south
africa are the battle of midway for
covet 19 outcomes
he says and some bullet points here a 7x
increase in new cases without increase
in mortality
no protection for previous natural
immunity no data for vaccine protection
so what do we get from that
um it's it's at least in south africa he
says it's created an enormous surge in
cases
7x increase
seven times increase
but no increase in mortality
and if that data holds up that means
that this thing is
ex this is an extremely mild strain
according to the data
so i ask again the question that i have
been asking which is um
if it's true
that omnicorn is an extremely mild
variant of covid
and that it's in 38 countries across the
world and nobody's died of it so far
the scientists who discovered it says
that uh you know basically it's it's
just cold symptoms for a few days for
most people very mild she said
well that's the case why are we trying
to contain
it know if we're if if we were
interested in getting past this why
would you take
the one the most mild strain of covid
and do everything you can to shut
everything down lock people away do what
you can to isolate it and get rid of
that strain
the safest
most mild strain why would you do that
that's a question largely a rhetorical
one but something to think about um what
else we got uh still on the on on covid
i got to play this for you
jimmy fallon and ariana grande and uh
meghan the stallion
they did a they have a christmas song
out now called masked christmas
all about wearing masks and getting your
booster before before you go to
christmas with your family
and i'm now going to subject you to
exactly 60 seconds of this here it is
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all
it's megan the stallion
ariana grande
and jimmy fallon
y'all know what time it is
it's time to get those
[Music]
[Music]
we'll posters in line for a boosters
[Music]
but
[Music]
i
okay
just cut out of this
all right okay
that we didn't get i was trying to do
the whole 60 seconds
because that's your punishment and uh i
couldn't even get through the entire
thing
you know
on the left they used to pretend to be
big critics of big pharma
any big corporation right any big
billion dollar industry big critics of
that and now we have one after another
this this is basically an ode to
pharmaceutical companies
it used to be a christmas song you know
that would be an ode to uh to jesus
christ who
who came here to save us from our sins
that used to be what you would sing
about on christmas and now
the new christ is the pharmaceutical
industry
well because sin doesn't exist
everything's been medicalized and so the
pharmaceutical industry they are now the
messiah the saviors and so now we're
going to get christmas songs that are
odes to the pharmaceutical company
disturbing to say the least speaking of
disturbing the jesse smellet trial is
ongoing i say it's disturbing it's
actually not i think the disturbing
thing is is that arguably it's a grave
human rights violation
that this trial is not being live
streamed
i mean this is some of the best comedy
of the century happening behind closed
doors out of you and we're not allowed
to see it
this is like i don't know it's like if
you go to saint peter's basilica and
someone throws a tarp over the pieta or
something this is this this this thing
of beauty out of view we can't see it uh
but we do have the reports
which only gives us uh a small taste of
what we're missing and this is from vice
it says jesse smallett finally took the
stand in his bizarre trial monday and
testified that he once masturbated with
one of the men he's accused of hiring to
attack him for attention
smolette said it all went down during a
visit to unfortunate phrasing there it
all went down during a visit to a bath
house with um
abimbola who's the one of the brothers
uh smolette is accused of paying this
guy to beat him up and yell racist slurs
and pour bleach on him in january of
2019. smellette recalled in the
courtroom we went alone we got a private
room we made out a little bit and this
time we masturbated together he's saying
all this on the stand
smilet also testified that after he met
the brothers at a club
they made out and did drugs during a
different bathhouse interaction
and so they're making out and having sex
and doing drugs all over the all over
the city the ex-empire stars testimony
built on the defense's line of
questioning last week when one attorney
first mullet dramatically asked one of
the brothers a major witness with
prosecution when he'd started dating
smollette and the brother said he never
did
and then we continue along and um
smilette says that he
uh he was asked about the fact that his
car was seen driving slowly past the day
before driving slowly past the the scene
of the of the hoax
and we know that that's because they
were scouting out spots to perpetrate
this hoax this con this scam but he says
it was no we were just driving along and
smoking a blunt
that's his defense in court is that they
were driving in smoking weed
um
he also talked about he was asked uh why
why didn't you call police right away
it took him a little while to call the
police
like why would you're at the scene of
this uh horrible hate crime you've been
attacked by by these nazis who poured
bleach and you put a put a
a noose around your neck why wouldn't
you immediately pull out your phone and
call the cops right then
at the scene of the crime
instead he went home and waited a little
bit and then he called him
and he still had the noose around his
neck so he kept it on
it's kind of like a fashion statement
for a couple of hours
and he was asked about that and he said
his answer was that he's a black man in
america so he's afraid of the police
so a couple things first of all
especially when we have this detail of
him you know the masturbation detail
i'd be i'm really interested to hear
jeffrey tubin's legal analysis of all of
this
probably cnn has has uh provided that so
i'd have to go check
um
but from what i can tell
jesse smallett's whole defense
is to just throw out all of his victim
cards because you might you might ask
yourself
how is any of this relevant to your
defense
so you you made out with a man
and engaged in these various sexual acts
uh how does that
how does that help you
it might not hurt you legally speaking
but how does it help why are you talking
about that as part of your defense and
the answer is
it's a victim card
so he's throwing them all out
and for the for his lawyers
you know you have to see where they're
coming from a little bit
this is all they have
because prosecution hasn't dead to
rights
it's it was it was it was obvious from
the beginning that this never happened
but you've got the people who he staged
the hoax with saying yeah that's exactly
what happened and here's the money he
gave me as proof he wrote me a check
justice mullet
jesse smallett
perpetrated a race hoax and wrote a
check to the people
and wrote on the memo line race hoax
he might not have done that but he did
write them a check
so they've got him all the evidence is
there and um
what do they really have and why is this
why are they even going to trial why are
they putting justice mullet on this on
the stand to begin with the answer is uh
it's just to throw out the victim cards
and hope that there's enough leftists
on given that this is chicago there
probably is it might actually work
i'm going to tell you right now i would
not be surprised if justice millett is
acquitted
in chicago
this defense strategy i wouldn't be
surprised if it works
he's throwing out all the cards he's
saying look i'm gay uh i'm a black man
look you see
i'm a marijuana user we'll throw that
into
i don't know if that's a victim group
now but let's let's give that a shot
will it work
as i said i wouldn't be surprised if it
does
okay uh what else do we got here
let me go up to this see if i can find
it okay uh from the daily water says
australian doctor philip nitschke has
announced that 3d printing devices that
are being coined euthanasia pods a
coffin-like device that makes assisted
suicide accessible for nearly anybody
and without medical intervention will
soon be available in switzerland nitshke
has said his purpose for making the
devices is so that anybody can commit
suicide with little medical assistance
insider reported monday morning that
swiss outlets that swiss outlet swiss
info
announced that sarco machines 3d printed
capsules designed for use in assisted
suicide have passed a legal review and
can now operate in switzerland
prototyped in the netherlands by dr
philip nishke the coffin-like sarco
capsule should be ready for operation in
switzerland in 2022
and then we get into details about how
this capsule actually works and here
they are
it's a 3d printed capsule activated from
the inside by the person intending to
die so they get into their own coffin
and
they make themselves comfortable it says
the machine can be towed anywhere for
the death it can be in an idyllic
outdoor setting or in the premises of an
assisted suicide organization for
example uh quote the person will get
into the casper capsule and lie down
it's very comfortable
they'll be asked a number of questions
and when they have answered they may
press the button inside the capsule
activating the mechanism in their own
time
the capsule is sitting on a piece of
equipment that will flood the interior
with nitrogen rapidly reducing the
oxygen level to one percent from 21 in
about 30 seconds the person will feel a
little disoriented and may feel slightly
euphoric before they lose consciousness
death takes place through hypoxia and
oxygen and carbon dioxide deprivation
respectively there is no panic no
choking feeling
he claims
um
and so these will be operational soon
and you can buy your very own death pod
your very own death chamber
take it outside you know go to the go to
the
maybe to a mountainside nice view
and kill yourself
a couple of points here
you know what's wrong with
legal assisted suicide
many many things we've talked about it
before we can't go i'm not going to go
into a whole exhaustive list
um
here's one thing though
the the doctor-assisted suicide a big
problem with it
is that now we are treating
death
as a medical
option
and we're putting we're putting doctors
in the position of being death merchants
now doctors that's that is an inversion
of of medicine
doctors traditionally taking the
hippocratic oath do no harm they're
supposed to treat and heal that's all a
doctor is supposed to do
and when doctors get into the business
of doling out death
then you have inverted the medical
profession and you might point out that
doctors already do that through abortion
and you're right
and we see the corruption that that has
created
across the medical field
not just among abortionists
and this only makes it worse this is not
another step in that direction
where death becomes medicine
i mean death cannot be medicine because
medicine is about treating human beings
um death is the is the annihilate is
annihilation it's the annihilation of a
human being
you cannot treat something through its
own annihilation
okay you can't you can't fix a building
by demolishing it
you might demolish a building and build
a new one in its place but you're not
you can't you can't claim that you're
fixing the building
and buildings are just buildings or
inanimate objects
is that how we want to treat human
beings we don't treat them
by saying well
you you're past your your use at this
point
now bring out the wrecking ball and get
rid of this one we'll get a new model
now this is not doctor assisted suicide
this is a product you can buy and so
instead in this case instead of doctors
being the death merchants instead of
instead of death being medicine
now death is a consumer product
it's something that you can buy
now you can have corporations in the
business of dispensing death
is that any better than death as
medicine
uh no i mean arguably it's worse
at least it's equal
so you have death as medicine death as a
consumer product
here's another question for you
if you are in the market shall we say
for
death
uh if you're looking to commit suicide
i want to be delicate about this because
of course i'm not i'm not recommending
this path i don't think anyone should
commit suicide and i think i think when
someone is suicidal
the the appropriate thing is to counsel
them away from that
obviously or it should be obvious
but it is an interesting question about
you know if somebody wants to commit
suicide why wouldn't they shoot
themselves in the head let's say
that that
one would think is probably the quickest
and painless way to go out most painless
way to go out
um
is
strapping yourself into a death pod
is is there less pain involved i don't
know i'm not gonna find out
but you would think something like that
is
pretty quick
efficient way of doing it um
so
why not that i mean if you're if you're
in the if you're in the uh the
euthanasia industry
and you're you're a proponent of
of
what they call assisted dying if you're
a proponent of suicide why would you
just recommend that to people
well one is that you can't profit off of
that okay uh because the death pills
cost money the death pods cost money
people are profiting so one is that's
why you don't recommend it the other is
that
you know
shooting yourself in the head is brutal
and violent
it's very clear what's happening it is
death
it's bloody it's gross
it's horrible
it's terrible it's all of those things
it's death that's what it is that's what
death is
um
but by
taking the suicidal person and putting
them in a pod or laying them down gently
on a bed and giving them a nice pill
you know now these are all kind of
visual euphemisms for for suicide
it's a way of sanitizing everything of
hiding from what you're actually doing
acting like it's something other than
death something other than annihilation
you know we could we it allows us to
talk about the suicidal person and not
even call them suicidal
which is what they are
it allows us to talk about suicide
without calling it suicide
we can use other other terms for it so
it's all about
not being uh it's dishonest that's one
of the other problems with euthanasia
it's dishonest
we're not being honest about what's
happening here about what these people
are choosing to do to themselves
um all right
one other thing this is from fox a new
exhibit at the smithsonian institution
features an interactive display that
incorporates the first genderless voice
assistant
just the news reported the voice
assistant known as q
is located at the futures exhibit and
the smithsonian's website declares it
describes it as a voice that was
synthesized by combining recordings of
people who identify variously as male
female transgender or non-binary
the futures exhibit located in
washington dc at the smithsonian art and
industries building had its grand
opening on november 20th and now you can
have you can
be guided through this exhibit with a
genderless voice assistant and this is a
big big development and uh we have an
example of what the genderless voice
sounds like and here it is
hi i'm q the world's first genderless
voice assistant
think of me like siri or alexa but
neither male nor female
i'm created for a future where we are no
longer defined by gender
but rather how we define ourselves
my voice was recorded by people who
neither identify as male nor female
and then altered to sound gender neutral
putting my voice between 145 and 175
a range defined by audio researchers
[Music]
okay
so wait a second
wait wait wait wait
the voice was recorded by people who
identify as neither sex but then you had
to change the voice you had to
manipulate it artificially to make it
sound like it's someone of neither sex
even though it still sounds basically
like a woman i mean it sounds like a
woman with strep throat or something
but what does that tell us
so you want a genderless voice and
supposedly there are genderless people
out there so why not just have one of
them come come and uh and record the
voice
well in fact that's exactly what they
did but then they had to manipulate it
through through the computer to make it
sound genderless
why is that because our voices are
naturally gendered quote unquote
because apparently even someone who
identifies as genderless even though
they might get an option now in the
drop-down menu when they're applying for
a job
um
they still have a gender and it comes
through in every part of them through
through
every every part of their being
it has has a gender or rather i should
say has a sex
including their voice
which is why you have to manipulate it
to get that result which is still not
very convincing okay let's get now to
the comment section
[Music]
did you know that garages are the most
frequently accessed entry to the home
you probably didn't but now you do often
overlooked the garage is where the
people most important to you come and go
and it houses many of your most prized
possessions including your cars tools
and bikes so it's just common sense to
know what's going on inside your garage
introducing the myq smart camera by
chamberlain the only smart camera
optimized for the garage brought to you
by the leaders in garage door opener
technology with features like live video
streaming recorded events motion
detection and two-way communication
right from your phone you can make sure
that your garage is secure 24 7. pair it
with the myq smart garage control and
you'll never have to worry if you left
the garage door open you can check it
see it and close it all from the my q
app from anywhere and that means if
you're like me and you've got the the
ocd problem where you know you check the
doors are locked 17 times you check that
the garage door is closed 17 times but
then on your way to work you still think
did i close the garage well now you've
got the app and you can check it there
and uh check that 17 times and then
close it so what are you waiting for
give the gift of a myq smart garage
camera to tech lovers this season if you
act now you can say 46 percent a very
specific number for a limited time by
entering walsh at checkout on my queue
dot com
that's walsh at checkout on myq dot com
slash walsh to say 46
keep an eye on what's happening in and
around your home's busiest entry with my
q smart garage camera it's the only
smart camera optimized for the garage
it's so sad this is from king edward
says it's so sad that in this time a
renowned lgbtq activist can't become a
beloved and successful children's author
without facing discrimination we truly
live in a society uh well i appreciate
that and and and uh you know that's that
is a burden
that uh that i carry as the nation's
leading
lgbt author leading children's author
leading lgbt voice um i carry that
burden
and uh it's made a little bit easier by
the fact that um you know i have a
bestselling book johnny the walrus at
johnnywalrus.com and uh oh by the way we
are also
speaking of johnny walrus
we are also on target now somehow target
is carrying the book not not physically
at their stores i don't think i mean
that would be great but you can go to
target.com and buy the book so
start to count down on that one i think
um abigail streier's book
was banned her irreversible damage her
book about the the transing of of our
daughters
that book was banned by target it was
originally carried by target and then
they banned it after two people
complained
so how many complaints will it take for
johnny walrus to get banned by target
we'll find out all right why are they
carrying it in the first place well
because it was written by an lgbt author
probably
let's see um
valve says matt the desk hole talking
about the uh one of one of camila
harris's underlings who took that really
disturbing photo yesterday trying to
prove that they are really happy to to
work for camilla harris but only proving
the opposite i remarked on the fact that
there was a a very suspicious looking
hole
on the bottom of the desk and i couldn't
quite figure out what it was there for
and you know i didn't i didn't i didn't
speculate about why it was there i
didn't i i don't think i implied
anything
i just said why is there a hole there
[Music]
you might be able to think of some
reasons why camala harris of all people
would have that hole in the desk
but i don't mean really anything by that
i just want to be clear
anyway valve says matt the desk hole is
most likely
for computer cords or other cords a vast
majority of desks
made now have them
all right well you have your theories
i have mine
i haven't said what those theories are
i'm not going to
christian says
uh i love how honest matt is about his
hatred of the advertising that's not
true
i love advertising my own stuff like
johnny the walrus at johnnywalrus.com or
my swag shack which you can go to
wire.com shop and buy all my stuff there
um
fabio says this is the first time i i
waited to listen to an lgbt plus author
and i listened to the whole show well
thank you for that thank you
it truly
it's you're showing that you are
open-minded and you're very tolerant of
of me
um and i i appreciate that i mean you
have no idea you you never thought that
by listening to this show the matt wall
show of all shows that you would earn
woke points but now you do
you are racking them up all the more
reason to listen
and share with all your friends
uh
eric says you're being criticized on
social media by some conservatives who
say that your book isn't good art slash
is just a gimmick i know you talked
about a little bit with clavin but i'd
be interested to hear you expand
um
yeah that's right there there have been
a few conservatives some of them at
least one of them anyway a children's
author and i have seen this and they've
been complaining like all since last
week that johnny the walrus is not
artistically acceptable that it isn't
good you know it should be better it's
not real art blah blah blah so a few
responses that i have noticed that a few
responses
um it's a parody kids book printed on
cardboard about a about a trans walrus
so were you expecting shakespeare
lighten up for god's sake
second
we have dominated the amazon charts
we've been named the top lgbt book we've
dominated the children's book market
and none of this is by accident
it's also because it's also not because
we paid for a really expensive marketing
campaign
we didn't even tell anybody this book
was coming out until we released it
there was no there was you know usually
to get to the top of the charts you have
all the you have all the pre-orders
before you you know before the book is
released
and we didn't do that we just released
it last monday
and we're doing all of this on platforms
that hate us
and hate our message
and hate this book
so what do we call that
that's called a win okay this is what a
win looks like
i know some conservatives don't they
don't really know what that looks like
they aren't used to it maybe they don't
even really like winning but that's what
this is about dominating with a book for
preschoolers that makes a mockery of
gender ideology um that's a big one so
here's my point why not enjoy it why not
cheer it on you know instead of looking
for reasons to criticize why not say
well this is a this is great
because when a similar thing happens on
the left i can tell you they don't do
this
they don't start criticizing each other
well yeah you know it's a win but i
don't really like the way you did it it
should have been done this other way
this way this way makes me feel weird it
makes my tummy hurt they don't do that
they say hell yeah we won
i mean some people on the right i swear
are just are losers
and they enjoy it they're addicted to it
and the third point is there's a lot of
envy on the right as well i think that's
that's one of our problems
we don't work together as a unit as a
team very well i mean i'm talking about
across the entire spectrum on the right
generally speaking and uh one of the
reasons that we don't is because people
get very envious
and uh if you have some success with
something other people on the right will
will be sad and they'll be jealous that
it wasn't them and then they'll come
after you
so i've experienced this i've also seen
it many times
and it's bad for the movement it's also
a bad business by the way it's bad
strategy
because now you've burned a bridge
and i'm not going to help you in the
future what i might have otherwise
i don't hold grudges but it's just a
simple common sense i'm not gonna go out
of my way to help someone who's publicly
attacking me right that's nobody does
that
so that's what that's all about and it's
it's pretty sad
and although it's kind of a cliche to
say it now this this is why we lose so
often it's never been more important
that americans get their news from
objective voices who value the truth
that's why we created our newest podcast
morning wire which has been topping the
apple and spotify charts since its
release and we're continuing our
commitment to bringing you the news
without a hidden agenda it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news that you
need to know we need your help to keep
the facts trending towards number one so
subscribe and start listening now to
morning wire apple spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts and leave a
five-star review if you like what you
hear and also
did i mention that i have this book
called jenny the walrus that just came
out you go to johnnyworth.com uh and if
you want to know what all the fuss is
about uh top lgbt book top children's
book one of the top books in the country
literary sensation
um you know
what what i'm being told what people are
saying is that they think it's it is
potentially one of the most influential
um
one of the most poetic and beautiful
works of literature ever written
i think people might be saying that i
haven't heard anyone say that but i'm
imagining they have anyway you can see
it for yourself go to johnnywalrus.com
and uh pre-order your copy today let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today i'm canceling ugly people um now
stick with me i'm not attacking those of
us who are aesthetically deficient
through no fault or choice of our own
we're safe
what i'm canceling instead is
intentional ugliness and not just as it
applies to human beings personally but
also to the works of human beings our
art our our architecture our music
there's ugliness everywhere
the world has become a very ugly place
now it retains its natural beauty you
can still go to san francisco and if you
step over the human feces and the meth
addicts laying all over the sidewalk and
if you can wade through the mob of
hoodlums looting the gucci outlet you
can look out at the ocean and it's just
as beautiful as it always has been
there's beauty in the world wherever
we've allowed it to remain but those
places are fewer and farther between as
there's been a campaign to uglify
everything including ourselves
as for the uglification of people tiktok
provides an extensive catalogue of such
cases here's one highlighted by libs of
tiktok in the video one female user
shows pictures of herself from some
years ago when she was a normal decent
looking young woman but but that has
changed let's watch this
[Music]
okay well if you couldn't see there
because you're listening to the audio
podcast she chopped her hair off she put
on weight
and she stuck piercings all over her
face
her feminine appearance is gone in favor
of this androgynous mutilated look i
feel comfortable commenting on the
transformation because she's apparently
quite proud of it proud enough to
advertise it on social media
she is certainly uglier now much uglier
and that's how she intends it
many such cases you find this trend even
among pop stars who used to be
criticized for being unreasonably
beautiful more and more they freed
themselves from the shackles of physical
beauty and embrace something else
entirely i saw an interview with demi
lovato recently where she was talking
about getting in touch with aliens
through meditation
and somehow that wasn't the weirdest
part of the interview the weirdest part
was her appearance she was sporting a
mullet
and a baggy button-down that looked like
something that she grabbed out of her
dad's hamper
again this is this is part of a larger
trend even the female celebrities who
remain beautiful don't want you to
notice it
supermodel emily ratajkowski was has
just released a book of essays
though you'd probably want to read an
essay by a supermodel about as much as
you want to see me posing for modeling
shots where she complains about the as
new york times puts it the oppression of
the male gaze
she has built a career on being
attractive in front of the camera she's
made millions off of the male gaze and
yet she hates it it oppresses her she
wishes she could climb into a cave and
model for no one and still get paid
millions
but there isn't much of a market for
cave modeling so she sticks with the
regular kind and whines about it
the attack on beauty also includes an
attack on those who notice or appreciate
beauty
yet ratajkowski's complaints aren't as
absurd as the rise of plus-sized
modeling where morbidly obese women don
skimpy clothing to show off their excess
baggage we're not meant to appreciate
their beauty i mean morbid obesity is
not beautiful since it's
self-destructive and deadly so much as
we're supposed to admire the physical
ugliness on principle
a few years ago calvin klein unveiled
massive billboards in interior in times
square with fat people posing in their
underwear
this is not beauty but a kind of
anti-beauty now as i said this extends
far beyond the physical appearance of
human beings when it comes to pop stars
as they grow increasingly uglier and
more weird and brutal in appearance so
does their music
think about think about this
how often do you do you hear a pop song
even one you like
and think wow this is beautiful
now you might like a song because it's
catchy or it sounds cool or whatever but
not usually because it's beautiful
there was a time most of human history
in fact when the statement i like this
music was synonymous with the statement
this music is beautiful the idea of
liking music for any other reason and
beauty would have seemed absurd it still
is actually
most music today even if it's catchy is
also nonetheless obnoxious and vulgar
and stupid and unpleasant
the same can be said about many of the
cars we drive while we listen to the
music and the buildings that we're
driving to
almost all buildings are ugly nowadays
we've gotten so used to it we don't even
notice it
but take note of it next time you're
driving anywhere
i mean the buildings are hideous almost
all of them
it only becomes noticeable when the
ugliness is directly supplanting
something beautiful that came before it
the notre dame cathedral in paris burned
and now they're going to replace it with
a contemporary monstrosity replete with
obnoxious light displays and modern art
and other forms of gaudiness
speaking of art modern art is defined by
its ugliness
it is like the tik-tok user ugly on
purpose
to make a point of some kind
but what is the point i mean why is
everything and everybody so ugly
why is the modern aesthetic so harsh and
ghastly and strange i think there are a
few things happening here let's talk
about two of them one
modern society revolts against standards
we celebrate ambiguity because we
imagine that there's freedom to be found
in that vague sort of fog
we seek to escape expectation
a woman rejects the standards of
femininity with its coherence and its
clear lines and calls herself non-binary
but a beautiful woman by definition is
one who best exemplifies those feminine
traits
a woman is most beautiful when she most
looks like a woman
that's one of the reasons why morbid
obesity is not beautiful on a woman or
on anybody
it's not beautiful on a woman because it
it
not only is it is it deadly and lethal
and unhealthy and self-destructive but
it also it also detracts from it
literally covers up
the feminine traits that make a woman
beautiful
just as the modern artist seeks to
escape standards and expectations by
painting painting random splotches on a
page and calling it a tree or whatever
but a beautiful painting of a tree is
one that most captures the essence of a
tree
the splotches are nothing in particular
so they can't be beautiful
two modern society is preoccupied by
convenience and utility we don't strive
for transcendence we don't recognize
that anything like transcendence can
exist we reject it as a category and so
we build giant grey depressing
nondescript buildings and we fill our
cities with them our ancestors built
palaces and cathedrals
i mean they were literally reaching up
towards the sky towards something
greater that's why they built those
buildings
we build really big shoe boxes
we live in the shoe boxes we work in
them we go to church in them
the designs are practical and cheap
they're useful
but they're not beautiful
beauty reaches for something beyond
beauty cares about truth
our culture
just
doesn't just fail to seek truth it hates
it
and it produces art and music and
architecture and people who reflect that
preference
so everything is ugly and ugly on
purpose
not on accident like me
and that is why purposeful ugliness
today is finally canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle our audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair makeup is
done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire
on today's episode new york city imposes
sweeping new vaccine mandates russia
prepares a military invasion of ukraine
and alec baldwin gives a controversial
interview about the fatal onset shooting
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire